the avengers
are assembling
bridger you're a rock star wow
you're a hero i mean you're just such a
brave little kid that brave little kid
is super six-year-old bridger walker of
wyoming
who well we'll let chris hemsworth
sometimes known as thor tell the story
we stood between the dog and his sister
and took the full full attack on himself
and then
received some pretty serious injuries to
his head and his face
but afterwards took his sister's hand
and brought her to safety
and when chris says pretty serious
injuries we're talking a two-hour
surgery and more than
90 stitches his four-year-old sister
escaped unharmed
according to his aunt bridger later said
quote if someone had to die
i thought it should be me you guys he's
six
the extraordinary bravery the courage
you showed in the face of fear
protecting your little sister
that's so inspiring the internet did its
thing and celebrities including
everybody's favorite superhero squad
came through avengers
assemble you know you're an avengers fan
and so myself and all the team
uh we'd be honored to have you on the
team mate and and we love you we're
sending you our support
mark ruffalo commented i truly respect
and admire your courage
and your heart i put the brains and the
brawn together
and now look at me and hathaway
captioned her post
i know a superhero when i see one and
zachary levi declared bridger
a member of the quote shazamly adding
hope i get to shake his hand someday
you're really on top of this but wait
there's more
on your left i'm going to track down
your address and i'm going gonna send
you
an authentic captain america shield
because pal
you deserve it i'm gonna do one better
you call me
on your next birthday i got something
special for you
i'm bringing the party to you we're
going to be shooting spiderman
if you ever want to come to set and hang
out see spiderman
up close and hang out with us you're
always welcome you'll always be my guest
he's really starstruck but thank you so
much
someone else who did it as in sent a
message to bridger
is brett michaels a superhero in his
field
a little every rose has its thorn this
one is for you
i hope this guitar brings you much love
much luck
all right
[Music]
enjoy my friend